Elon Musk may be the superstar CEO of SpaceX
but a lot of the credit goes to the guy who was
instrumental in making the rockets fly. I'm Tom
Mueller, I'm a co-founder of the company. Tom
Mueller may not be famous like Musk but he's a big
part of the reason the company is as successful as
it is today. As Vice-President of Propulsion and
later the Propulsion Chief Technology Officer,
he led the design, testing, and construction of
SpaceX's engines. Before joining SpaceX, Mueller
developed engines at TRW, a large aerospace company
in Los Angeles later acquired by Northrup Grumman.
As a hobby, he spent weekends testing and
flying his own machines in the Mojave desert
with an amateur rocket club called Reaction
Research Society. That's how he met Musk almost
20 years ago through the club. The future SpaceX
CEO had been looking to recruit a bright team
of engineers to build rockets. The year before, Musk
had gone to Moscow to try to buy refurbished ICBMs
but when the Russians wanted too much money, he set
out to build his own rocket for less. So when it
came time to founding SpaceX, Musk saw in Mueller
someone who knew everything there was to know
about rocket engines. When I met Elon it's like, wow
I'd really like to go do this thing. It's high risk but
it's where I want to be. Going to a startup was
risky but also gave him free reign to do more.
Mueller is known for developing rocket engines
from scratch including the Merlin engine. This
is a 95,000-pound thrust engine. Basically this
engine will burn a hole right through concrete.
These engines power the Falcon line of rockets.
The 27 in the Falcon Heavy generate over 5
million pounds of thrust at liftoff. And the
Falcon 9 gets its name from the nine Merlin
engines in the first stage. They're fueled
by rocket-grade kerosene and liquid oxygen.
It's not easy developing an engine
that can withstand a 170-second burn-
long enough to send a payload into orbit and then
return safely to Earth. Merlin revolutionized
space flight as it's designed to be reused.
Building reusable rockets put SpaceX on the map.
It's now a common sight to see the Falcon 9 first
stage perform one of its signature landings. Last
year, that rocket launched astronauts aboard the
Crew Dragon to the International Space Station.
Mueller also developed the engines that helped
the Dragon spacecraft maneuver while in orbit. Well
before these achievements, Mueller was right beside
Musk during the company's most difficult days
when attempts to launch its first rocket, the
Falcon 1, kept failing. The third time it tried
to fly into orbit, the first stage rear-ended
the second caused by a small amount of residual
thrust from the first stage after the engine was
cut off. SpaceX had enough money to scrounge up a
fourth and what would have been final flight if
it failed. This time, the team told the rocket to
wait a few more seconds after the engine was cut
off before stage separation. Fourth time's a charm.
The Falcon 1 became the first privately
developed liquid fuel rocket to orbit
the planet which led to a billion-dollar
contract with NASA that saved the company.
Mueller has been an integral part of the story
of SpaceX from the start but he almost never
became an engineer if it were not for some sage
advice. As the son of a logging truck driver raised
in a small town in Idaho, being an engineer
wasn't something he considered. He wanted to
be an aircraft mechanic. Then I took a math class
when I was a freshman in high school and my math
teacher said to me, "Do you want to be the guy that
fixes a plane or the guy that designs the plane."
That was a pivotal point of my life. Of course I
wanted to be the guy that designs the plane. No
one had told me that I had the aptitude to be an
engineer. I didn't even know what an engineer did.
That teacher changed my life. He spent summers
logging to pay his way through college studying
mechanical engineering at the University of Idaho.
After graduation, he set out for California and
its thriving aerospace industry but instead
of finding a job designing planes, he wanted to
work on his childhood passion: rockets. I realized
that that was a key decision. A fork in the road
where I made the right choice to do what I love.
Don't settle. Put yourself on the right
path and end up where you want to be.
After a storied career at SpaceX, he stepped
back into a part-time advisory role in 2016
as Musk in the propulsion department led the
development of new engines for a new rocket.
This could be the first engine to take people
to Mars. Raptor engines power SpaceX's fully
reusable rocket, Starship. They're fueled
by liquid oxygen and liquid methane.
Methane could possibly be made on the red
planet for the journey home. As SpaceX soars
to new heights, much of its achievements can be
traced back to the early work of Tom Mueller.
In fact, Musk acknowledged his contributions were
critical to SpaceX's success. The man who helped
make the rockets fly officially retired in late
2020, capping off a nearly two-decade career at
SpaceX which has been, in his words, "quite a ride".
Ability plus luck equals success. If you have the
ability then luck is your opportunity. Mueller
may have met the right visionary at the right
time but it took more than luck to win Musk over. A
great engineer requires a solid background in math,
science, and computer science. Whether you'd like to
brush up on the math you learned as an undergrad,
want to take up programming, or simply wish to
expand your critical thinking through logic
courses, you can sign up for free with Brilliant,
Brilliant offers over 60 interactive courses.
There are no tests and if you happen to
answer incorrectly, my sponsor Brilliant
explains where you went wrong. You can register
with the link in my description and the first
200 people to use my link will get 20% off
the Premium subscription which gives you
unlimited access to all the courses. Thanks so
much for watching. For Newsthink, I'm Cindy Pom.